Dới chứ không gấp dẫn, có điều tra phụ trảy tại khu tổ hợp của ông Fuh Khoa tiếp tục đường mừng giống.
Bới tổng cộng người mà đối tượng mi bắt sử, đi phụ vụ làm só có giấu hiệu vi pham trong quả trình cải tạo công trình.
Mù trảy sảy ra ngày 20 xo thông vi một đá khi 1 trong năm mông người thiệt mặt,
bởi đường đánh giá là tham cịch tối tệ nhất tại đặcu trong nhiều thập kỳ.
Kết quả, kìm cho bán đầu trưa thấy lưới trai giảm giá,
tại các toàn nhà liên quan, không đáp ứng tiêu chuẩn phòng trảy.
Trong 2,5 đục lấy từ bún toàn nhà có bệnh mẫu không đặt yêu cầu.
Điều tra của phát hiện các nhà thầu đã thấy thay phần lưới đi hư hài sau báo bằng bật liệu cánh trưa lượng.
Đông thời lắp đặt lưới đặt cho nữ khu vực giễ kiểm tra nhăm trắng bị phát hiện.
Chính quyền hông cơm là tuyên bố đề tăng băng ai và chính khai lực lượng tìm kiểm nhận giận lạm nhận với cường đục cầu.
Hoặc mua phân tức xúc cân hồ hiện chưa thì tất cả nguồm mất an tàn kết cấu.
Công tắt tìm kiểm giận kiểm cộng dài từ bài để bún toàn.
Để cình đó, huy hỗ trợ hoàng phu khó đánh nhận được chiến trong trường đồ lạm cân.
Tiền quyền góc, nâng tầm một lực lấy khoảng 1.2 tỷ để huy trợ tàn kết và giúp cơm dân ổn địa của sống sau thảm hòa.